it's been more than a week since turkey
launched its military operation in North
Assyria a campaign against the Syrian
Kurdish group and the YPG Turkey stays
the YPG is the Syrian branch of the
Kurdistan Workers Party or PKK the
turkey the EU and the US have listed as
a terrorist organization and this
operation is to stop what tricky calls a
terror corridor near its border the US
EU and the Arab League have called on
Turkey to halt the operation a request
Ankara has rejected president Recep
Tayyip Erdogan has laid out his own
conditions on how to end the separation
wouldn't agenda TechTV miss hey man our
proposal is that right now tonight all
the terrorists lay down their arms their
equipment and everything destroy all the
traps and get out of the safe zone that
we have designated the YPG is an
important element of the Syrian
democratic forces the SDF which help the
u.s. push ISIL out of large parts of
Syria but Ankara is offensive against
them has prompted the Syrian government
to move back into some parts of the
northeast under an agreement with the
SDF the Syrian army has not been here in
years an American delegation including
the vice president Mike Pence and the
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo are
expected in Turkey by Thursday president
Trump has decided to send the highest
level delegation he could possibly send
for diplomatic purposes other than
himself right I mean the vice president
and the Secretary of State and I'm sure
they're convinced of their own
persuasiveness will the full force of
the US government behind them but i i i
think that president air Dewan there's
no chance he's going to implement a
ceasefire or
allow any mediation until he feels
turkey has achieved the goal is that he
define Washington has put sanctions on
Turkey and is threatening to impose more
if the Syrian operation doesn't end when
it comes to Syria alliances shift
quickly on the ground and on the
negotiating table the mainly Kurdish SDF
feels abandoned by the US and has now
turned to the Syrian government that
once called it a tree
but one thing is clear for Turkey
Kurdish fighter group in northern Syria
poses a serious threat to its existence
scene mq solo al Jazeera Istanbul